today on the program i've got austin
allred back on the pod you know him as
the outspoken
ceo and co-founder of lambda school he
was on the pod i don't know what six
months ago
oh it would have been like 18 months ago
18 months ago a long time ago
yeah uh and i know things have been
going great but there's also been a
little bit of uh a brouhaha
so thanks for coming on the pod to talk
about that we'll get into that in the
first uh
segment catherine boyle is here she's a
partner at general catalyst and
formerly a journalist uh like myself uh
she was at the washington post from
2010 to 2014. so you'll have some some
uh feelings
yes all the feelings all the feels
all right well let's just get right into
it uh everybody knows lambda school
is trying to teach people how to code
and i saw
a new york magazine article was it two
weeks ago now that you've been
dealing with something like that and
they allege you misrepresented some
stats on graduation
50 versus 86 percent um they
seem uh to be confused a little bit
about the isas income sharing agreements
uh maybe some complaints about the
enrollment
and uh maybe the team leaders are
overtaxed or under
prepared is what they claimed you came
out and were super transparent
you explained exactly what the confusion
is uh you've had
times when you've had 85 percent of
graduates uh
get hired which is unbelievable uh
you've had
uh the article referenced a 50 hiring
rate but that was in the risks part of
your
uh deal memo in a mock exercise yeah
correct let me speak to this just so
yeah explain this to everybody
who saw this brouhaha at a high level
when we talk to investors we talk in
terms of enrolled students because our
costs all come from enrolled students
right so we'll say of those students who
were enrolled x percent were hired
whereas when schools report publicly
they speak in terms of
graduated students right um so obviously
those two numbers are always going to be
different because some people will drop
out and then you'll have a different
denominator right so the
reporter just took a number that was
different and compared it against a
different
metric um that said that 86
was somewhat out of date like it had
been a while since we updated our
numbers but it was the most
up-to-date number we had so we you know
quickly put together what the real
numbers
would have been um which was 78 percent
instead of 86
which is basically the same number but
not drastic well i mean it's going to
change between
classes as well correct of course of
course um so
it was i
yeah it was somebody who didn't
understand
what numbers they were looking at
comparing two different things
and also you refer to this person as a
reporter in fact i'm in touch with the
person
because you know i was defending you
publicly i'm not an investor to be clear
but i just thought this was like a slam
piece that was ridiculous i defended you
publicly he got in touch with me and i
was like
there's something weird here how long
have you been running i don't see any
other bylines for you and this person is
a a founder not correct
a journalist so when they approached you
did you know they were not a journalist
and they were another founder writing
what is for new york magazine what an
opinion piece well so when he approached
he said hey
you know i'm writing an article about
the
the code bootcamp space in general um
and could i get you know a couple lines
from you which you know we do that stuff
all the time they're
writing you know isas are a new thing
they're trying to understand
um but yeah it was and then it came in
very aggressive and on the phone when
you talk to him uh
he actually came into the office came to
the office and then got aggressive in
person
i mean i would call it aggressive i i
don't you know aggressive questioning
yeah it was it was intense right like
more intense than any other
and you know we we've had other bad
articles written about us but nothing
quite like that
i don't it's just weird what was the axe
to grind do you think because he seemed
to have some code
product that he was working on
previously i asked him what his axe to
grind was and he
yeah he was just straight up like
austin's a liar and i was like well
it doesn't seem like that and it seems
like the overwhelming
people number of people coming to lambda
school of getting jobs
yeah i don't know this is something that
i've been trying to figure out is why
i mean there is a very small pocket of
people who very much do not like me
um join the club yeah welcome to the
club catherine's laughing here she's
like what are they giving me something
oh well you're outspoken yeah i'm
definitely outspoken and
i think he felt like we were like i'm
above and beyond in
our marketing which is fair at times but
it's certainly
never been fraudulent or intentionally
misleading or anything like that